i think i'm kind of constitutionally
just
geared to to just keep going i don't
know um
it's uh
um
yeah i mean it just i
i don't know i mean it certainly there
are times when
things don't go well and then
uh that's quite dispersing for sure
um
and so then it's difficult to proceed
with the same level of enthusiasm um
but
um
but i do think like i do think the
things that we're doing are are you know
pretty
important to the future
um and if we don't succeed then
you know there's
well
there's not it's not clear what other
things would succeed
um and if if we don't succeed then we'll
be certainly pointed to as a reason why
people shouldn't even try for these
things
so
i think it's important that we do
whatever is necessary to keep going
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how
billionaires think to get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
rule number two have the right approach
with warren buffett it's very important
to have the right framework you need
you need
you need to have an approach to
investing that sound and graham's
approach is is simple
uh
but some people
uh
adopt to it and and
which i did immediately and and most
people don't
but if you have the right philosophy
you will find opportunities
uh as you go through the next 20 30 40
50 years rule number three know your
numbers with tillman fertitta this is
the problem with college and is that
they teach you the theoretical side of
everything for the person that's working
for you but it doesn't teach you to be
the ceo the practical side and the young
entrepreneur whether you're trying to go
up the corporate ladder or you are doing
it you're on and it's just the simple
things of and these are some of my great
tillmanisms from the book and why
harpercollins came to me and asked me to
write this book was
know your numbers okay you've got to
know your numbers there are no spare
customers we're all in a consumer
business
people watching this podcast for you or
me serving casino customers restaurant
customers hotel customers there are no
spare customers we're all after the same
consumer to the 95 5 rule that 95 of
everything is right so look for the 5
that's wrong
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four learn from your
failures with mark cuban i've been an
entrepreneur my entire life as far back
as i could remember i would sell
baseball cards as my friends i would buy
and sell stamps and stamp collections i
mean i was i was that kid in the
neighborhood that was always trying to
sell you something i sold garbage bags
door to door but after after actually
after i graduated from college i was
like what what can i do i want to start
my own business i don't want to get a
regular job um and so somebody came up
to me and had this great idea that i i
should try and they're like look milk's
so expensive
if we sell powdered milk
we can sell it for less and i'm like
that's a great idea so i started going
out there and finding these powdered
milk formulas
and the problem was it didn't taste so
good but i was like well people don't
need good tasty milk if they save a lot
of money
so that business lasted about two weeks
but i learned you know you that you
learn from your failures i mean
like i always tell people it doesn't
matter how many times you fail you just
have to be right one time then everybody
can call you an overnight success rule
number five solve a problem with jeff
bezos blue origin is a um
a space a company that's developing a
vertical takeoff vertical landing
space vehicle
uh and uh so it takes off on its
tail like a normal rocket and then comes
back and lands on its tail like a buck
rogers rocket it's designed to be
reusable
we've built our first development
vehicle we built our second development
vehicle we're right now working on our
third development vehicle great team of
engineers located in seattle another
team of people uh tests and operations
in west texas where we do our flights
and uh it's
it's proceeding along very nicely uh i'm
hopeful that this third development
vehicle will be our last but we can't
know for sure and then we will uh
build our operational vehicle and start
taking people to
suborbital uh mission we'll sell tickets
the long-term goal of blue origin is to
not only do suborbital but also orbital
and to democratize
space travel so that anybody who wants
to go into space can afford to do so you
need reusability
so when you go look at any approach that
doesn't have reusability is never going
to be low cost there are only two
problems with space travel today it's
too expensive and it's too dangerous
other than that it's fine so we hope to
solve
those two problems and if you want to
solve those problems
and have a space-faring species
you need to
you need to practice
and you can't practice with expendable
vehicles and it's like you know it's
flying your
you know you get onto 747 with a bunch
of other passengers fly to hawaii and
then throw the whole plane away it's
just a bad
it's a bad cost structure and
so we need reusability so you have to
get the vehicle back
and
one of the ways to get it back is to put
wings on it
and then you can land it on a runway
another way to get the vehicle back is
to
land it vertically under
under rocket power and both techniques
have advantages and disadvantages one of
the things i like about vertical landing
is
if you get it to work it's very scalable
scales to very very large size whereas
wings sort of you know they top out a
bit rule number six be truthful with
oprah winfrey you make the choice every
day
every single day to exemplify honesty
because the truth
let me tell you something about the
truth
the truth exonerates
[Music]
and it convicts
it disinfects
and it galvanizes the truth has always
been and will always be
our shield against corruption our shield
against greed and despair the truth is
our saving grace and rule number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is set big goals with grant
cardone i think the reason why people
drop their financial goals is because
the goals aren't big enough
the the the
you know if you make another 20 pounds
or another 200 pounds or another 2 000
pounds it doesn't change your life the
goals are too small to start with
but if you go from a million to 100
million
all of a sudden everything changes
you go from 100 million to a billion
yeah it changes again dude it's like
you go from a billion to a 10 billion
dollar company yeah you're like okay
wait a minute now now this is getting
really serious if you're a money
motivated person yeah and i know a lot
of people aren't right a lot of people
just
they've just given up on it
but why did they give one because well
they've given up on it so it doesn't
even matter because this entire
conversation is going to agitate them
so they're like i don't want to they
probably already tuned out they tuned
out already i mean i i didn't even get
them in time i should have told them
that they were going to tune out as soon
as i started talking about this but
uh and then we could have kept them yeah
um
but if you haven't given up on the money
thing
you you know you need to unders you just
need to do some math and and you need to
understand there's most of the people
that you're listening to on social media
have given up on the money game yeah i
know guys that have five million dollars
to have given up
now the trip i just we're on our 31st
day if you got five million dollars in a
bank account you cannot do the trip i
just did yeah okay you can't do the trip
you you don't have enough money to do
the trip man this is with the guy with
five million dollars he made five
million and quit yeah dude he was just
getting rolling he's like i don't need
anymore or his wife said we don't need
anymore we're good let's just enjoy life
okay if you can enjoy life at fit five
million dollars i'll guarantee you at 50
you're going to have a hell of an
experience and you bank 500 million and
you're going to be like no now
it's getting real interesting not just
for yourself either because if you if
you got five million dollars you can't
only take so many people with you
i'm dragging people from all over the
all over the world with me man that
they're having experiences my daughters
are having experiences the nanny the
nanny who's doing the homeschooling
she's like oh my god this is the best 30
days of my life so when you get big
enough man when you get big enough you
can feed other families
you almost have to have that drive like
in other words you can't fake it you
can't like pretend that you want to read
about ted turner and okay i'll skip one
movie
your soul yeah i mean you can fake it
too you make it in a lot of areas
particularly if you're working for
somebody else but at the end of the day
um
if you're going to be
created something you've got to make the
effort to be great at something um
whether it's sports whether it's physics
math science business whatever it may be
you know it's not just a natural skill
you've got you've got to
to learn and particularly if you're in
the technology industry because it
changes every day you know
when i got started
and and you know after i got i i got it
i was a bartender when i first came to
dallas got into the pc industry got
fired started my own company but
there i learned early on that there was
always something new and most people
didn't put in the time to learn it it's
like now with artificial intelligence
lots of people talk about artificial
intelligence lots of people talk about
machine learning and neural networks not
a lot of people are putting in the time
to take classes or do the tutorials or
to to learn how to apply it to business
and that's what it takes and and you
know that's just something i've always
enjoyed so that i've been fortunate what
industry you think still requires a lot
of innovation
all of them
seriously i mean look
one of my dad's favorite sayings was you
don't live in the world you were born
into
everything changes all the time and you
know what's better than change creating
change and so whenever i see something
that's done the way it's always been
done
you know like when i got to the nba
you know my whole goal is just to have
things up right because they everything
was done the exact same way they thought
they were in the business of basketball
for 50 years they thought they were in
the basketball business no you when you
go to a basketball game you don't
remember the jump shots the dunks you
remember who you were with the fun you
had it's one of the few industries when
that ball is in the air at the end of a
game
everybody holds their breath and your if
it goes in you're hugging people you've
never seen before you you know so you
can take any industry and look at the
way things have been done and try to
come up and innovate and
you know and like i said with just the
nature of capitalism right now all the
changes that are required
every industry needs change and there's
a unique opportunity that i don't think
any generation has ever seen the first
question you're going to get asked when
you go to apply for a job whether it's
now or some point in the future is what
did you learn what did you do what
skills did you add during the pandemic
of 2020 and i think it's imperative to
anybody looking to to get a job to
really push themselves forward to do
better than their parents to really
place a focus on learning you know i i
think you'd agree mike and anybody
watching that one of the greatest skills
that we all can have in the in the
business world is a thirst for knowledge
just being excited about learning and
knowing how to learn and this really is
the best opportunity
ever for people to add to their skills
whether it's taking a coursera class or
you know in the past i would have said
reading a lot of books but now having
learned from my kids going on youtube
and you know watching um tutorials and
watching videos on various subjects you
know i learned how to write a
three-letter three-layer javascript
neural network on youtube and so there's
a unique opportunity now for you to add
skills particularly in areas like
artificial intelligence
that are going to be in great demand
that most people have not yet learned
because you know it's it's so recent
that it's become really applicable if i
sit with a hundred dollars in my pocket
folks there is no economy
if you want to be economic you let money
flow it has to move you got people in
your company managers and executives
that are saving money they save their
money i'm like what are you doing dude
we're saving money how can you grow a
department if you go home and all you do
is save [ __ ]
you know you open up somebody's freezer
and they got ice cream that's three
months old it's got this much left in
you you got you got diet coke that's
four days old it's got that much left in
it okay you got ziploc containers you
have whole cabinets of ziploc containers
and little plastic things where you in
case you had some leftover corn or peas
or potatoes you're like
don't throw it away
save that
save that that much pork chop maybe i'll
hit it tomorrow
see somebody put this back in here
that's probably elena doing that there's
no reason to put this back here it
reminds me of my mama
reminds me of when i grew up save
everything
it's a terrible product anyway why you
want to save it look at this she put two
apples in here don't put them back in
the refrigerator man
eat them or toss them
you're not going to go broke
or get rich
saving leftovers
what are you guys doing man you got [ __ ]
in your closet that you ain't ever gonna
wear it don't fit you it ain't fit you
in in years
right how many of you got stuff at your
house you could get rid of
you're trying to save stuff
dude how can you how can you have new
stuff come in when you're holding on to
stuff that you don't even use
right so you have to use this it only
becomes valuable when it's used
now the question is what are you going
to use it on and the other question is
why don't you use it
why are you so compelled to hold on to
it
what do y'all think that is
you know how to get more number one
reason i don't your mother did not know
how to get a new shirt that's why she
took so much put so much time and energy
in cleaning the shirt you got a stain on
okay you broke a toy your parents got
upset with you can't believe you did
that
what did what man dude
toys are to be broken
that's what a good toy is for
right
right i lost a quarter when i was eight
years old and i would have thought i
would have thought my house
was gonna get torn apart because my dad
became so upset about the quarter you're
playing with money never play with money
what are you doing playing with money
and that that that lesson pounded on me
so hard it kept me from making real
money for 20 years it does not matter
who you know
it matters who knows you
so i'm going to go up i'm going to go
i'm trying to get to feed you right
okay look i mean i could know some i
could know some people that own places
in fiji but what if it's already booked
they can't kick them out
but what if people in fiji knew i was
coming they're like hey mr cardone i
want them calling me i don't want to
call them
and so who knows you we're back to the
question who's got my money who's got
your money is who knows you people do
business with people they know
it's how business has been done for two
thousand years in this plan not people
don't do business with people they trust
they do but they first do business with
people they know
i got to know you before i trust you
and i would rather do business with
somebody i know
and don't trust i do business with
people every day i don't trust
every day
i have to don't you think there's
there's an element of so for example but
i know they want to get this deal i know
they can get the deal done with me right
like the real estate broker i know i'm
not getting quite the truth from him on
this or that but you know what he's got
the deal i just did two deals i did 120
million dollars worth of real estate
deals with the same guy
i don't really like him right but i'm
doing business with him
and and this is not a new thing for
anybody anybody that's not doing
business with people they don't want to
do business with is lying
there's somebody you got people that
work for you you don't like
so what if you're having problems right
now
okay like like if you're having
recurring problems
just make a list
make a list of
make sure you guys do what grant says
remember he's a t-rex
yeah yeah make a list
make a list of your recurring problems
that you're sick of
the same stuff over and over again man i
don't have enough time i don't have
enough money
uh i i don't get to take whatever the
recurring problems are i can't good good
people uh uh i i got a i got one person
in my office that i depend on and i'm
sick and dependent on him even though
he's a producer
those recurring problems that you have
over and over again
uh you lose deals you lose you don't you
don't like your clients you actually
have clients that that you'd like to get
rid of you know how you get rid of bad
clients get more of them
okay so what i do is if i have problems
let's say i'm making a million dollars a
year i'm making one million
and i'm like okay next year this is what
this is what business owners do
they're like i'm this year i'm going to
go from 1 million to 1.2 million i'm
gonna get a little growth and then covid
cracks you
and then you're like okay i'll settle
for 500 grand now
the problem was you were looking for
incremental growth okay you know the old
thing about three steps forward two
steps backward you only get one step out
of that by the time by the time a week
or two goes you're like [ __ ] i'm sick of
this
i'm tired i'm bored
i'm beat up and your life doesn't change
the trick is
that if you would plan out how to get to
10 million even though you're not let me
just go ahead and asterisk that right
now
don't have a plan to go from one
to one point two
build a plan to go from one to ten
million because it's going to give you a
new set of problems
okay and a takeaway for you today get
new problems
because if you keep
working on the set of problems that you
have you will never solve them
okay watch uh i got a handful of
problems i'm making a million dollars a
year or 200 grand or whatever your
number is pick your number
and i'm like i'm gonna get me
incremental growth how do i do that with
the people i have the time i have the
office i have
well what you do is you're like i'm
gonna go from one million to ten million
oh i need a new office new problem
oh i need ten people not two people
oh i need to spend
a hundred grand a month on advertising
not five thousand see got all of a
sudden i got new problems
i'm no longer thinking about pete the
the the the uh
uh what do they call the guy that you're
so the diva the diva jessica i gotta put
up with jessica's [ __ ] because she's
a diva comes in when she wants leads
when she wants
uh she runs the business even though i
own it she tells me what to do she's
really the boss even though i write the
checks
okay so i'm like i'm gonna go get 20
jessica's you follow what i'm saying i'm
going to build
like a lot of you are worried about debt
i remember in 2008 i owed 50 million
dollars to the bank
and i'm like i told my wife this will
never happen to me again the bank was
pushing me around like bullying me
around like a punk
and and i said elena this will never
ever happen to us again and she's like
what are you gonna do to prevent it i
said the next time this country goes
upside down i'm gonna owe a billion
dollars in debt what's your main message
on your heart right now to people in
this time
i would keep i would pay people
i would look at the things just like i
said about number one find out what and
who you need to cut
same thing i would tell a household what
and who do you need to cut from your
life
is there some obligation you have that
you don't need going forward cut it
yeah financial is there people in your
life that you could afford to have in
january and you can't afford to have
many more you got to cut them you got to
boss up right now you got to be you got
to do the tough thing if you want to
take care of your tribe your group your
family
you have to do
leadership is it requires tough
decisions
unpopular decisions when 2008 happened i
had nothing to do with 2008 i had two
businesses and i was starting to buy
real estate and i was not buying the
real estate to cause the problem in this
country any of you remember when lehman
collapsed
uh your business if you were in business
your business probably got hurt
i wasn't doing the mortgage-backed
securities i wasn't doing the no money
down houses
you know i wasn't selling that stuff i
wasn't doing mass development on the
backs of the bank
with bad loans
but
because i lived in america
and i was doing business at the time
i got greatly affected by that my first
two businesses got cut in half and my
real estate was frozen up i owed 52
million dollars to a bank that went
upside down new bank came in they
started making demands on me i ended up
in a lawsuit aren't there a bunch of
lawyers in here yeah i ended up i ended
up in one of these crazy lawsuits where
the guy was going under he had done some
things wrong and he decided to pull me
down with it
it was a frivolous lawsuit that was
costing me 200 grand a month to fund
i've never been involved in a lawsuit in
my career
so that being said um
i looked at that situation and said hey
what did i do wrong here
like i always look at how am i
responsible responsible
able to respond that is the definition
of responsible able to respond
now in my case i was being forced to
respond
it wasn't a lot of able in it
so uh
but the one thing that i walked away
with was i had a baby on the way i just
been married i just got married maybe
three years before that so the marriage
was very new
we were we were really still in the
honeymoon phases of our marriage
not really understanding
who we were as a team my wife and i new
baby coming along
i lived in los angeles i lived in a
beautiful house up in the hills
uh overlooking all of l.a and i pretty
much thought my life was great until
2008 happened
now i'm taking a second to get you to to
what i want you to hear i didn't plan on
2008 i didn't think about a lehman
collapse i didn't know
40 million people were going to go
upside down in their homes i did not
know it would affect me i didn't know
one of my industries was the automobile
dealers i was working with automotive
meal dealers around the united states
that was my primary business
i was making a couple million bucks a
year i didn't know
9 000 car dealers would go out of
business
who would plan on any of that
now what's that got to do with today
who in their business plan had coved as
part of your business plan
let us know in the chat put put put a no
in the chat if you didn't have a plan
for that yeah i need to see 316. i need
to see one
one guy in here say oh yeah
i planned on mask
oh yeah i had i had myself going out one
week buying
400 worth of toilet paper
okay
uh
oh yeah in 2020 by the way how many of
you in 2020 january first you're like
this is gonna be the best [ __ ] year
of my life
oh yeah
yeah everybody gave that up on march
23rd the entire nation of america
gave up
surrender 2020.
look the news the media by by april was
saying 2020 is over how many of you
heard that [ __ ] i'm throwing 20 20
away fortune 500 companies 100 companies
carnival cruise lines general motors
ford motor company like mass companies
were like i'm done i'm tapping out
this year's over
wall street every day i'm watching
bloomberg right now wall street's like
hey just throw away all the earnings for
2020. let's reboot for 2021. the entire
nation
surrendered uh your kids aren't going to
schools
you didn't plan on that did you
see this is the problem with the concept
i think i saw somewhere in your promo go
big or go home
go big or go home ain't nothing at home
folks
there ain't nothing at your house you're
not gonna make your business work at
home
okay go big or go home or home you need
to scratch that out and say look i gotta
go big or i gotta go bigger because
going home cannot be a choice now and
the whole country went home we've been
quarantined you're going to have 10
million probably 8 to 10 million
bankruptcies by the end of this year the
the other shoe is not dropped yet the
stock market's going crazy the rich are
getting richer and and i don't include
us on this call as the rich the rich
will get richer
okay you why because they think big
they think big they never waste a crisis
and we are in a crisis
and the crisis if you were in trouble
before kovid you are in more trouble
today and the reason we're in trouble is
because people in this country are
satisfied complacent
comfortable these are the enemy so if
you can take anything away from me it's
like look you have you and your wife you
and your husband you and your kids must
give up ideas of comfort how do you
maintain a positive
opportunistic upbeat attitude during
times like this
you know i i look i struggle with it
just like everybody else this is not an
easy time it's scary uncertainties
everywhere
bad news everywhere
uh the thing the thing that i continue
to do is
i was just telling jared a few minutes
ago we're just thinking too small
you know let's let's we're thinking too
small
and so like i'm like where am i going
where am i trying to get to
uh because i could be seduced into a
beach right now pretty easily yeah i'm
gonna go lay on the beach
and i don't need to do all this you know
and then i'm like wait a minute there's
no beaches open either like there's the
caribbean shut down the damn
st bart's is shut down there's uh
everywhere you go there's problems right
so there's no getting away from that
where am i going yeah
so so i the thing i need to wake up
every morning hey i'm still going for 10
billion worth of real estate maybe 20.
yeah
why not 30.
so how do i do that got to stay relevant
got to keep paying my bills got to take
care of my properties got to show people
that i know how to get through tough
[ __ ] you can't expand if you if you fold
every hand you can't win if you fold
every hand
so you got to play the cards you got
right now it's tough
and then but i have to keep making
contacts with people that can actually
benefit me in 21 22 23.
um
i got i got to be i got to be a beacon
of possibility and potential and future
uh so so that when we go when things
start lifting off and we can do deals
um
i'm relevant to the conversation and i
got to cross my fingers dude and just
believe that
i got to believe that things are going
to get better
like if you just study a little bit of
history we've survived everything when
you get a 1 000 on your s.a.t
i probably got like a 980 i've convinced
myself that i broke a thousand
creativity becomes a survival skill it's
a necessity to get into the door to
interview to sell everything for me
revolved around so one day at the
recording studio i walk in and there's a
cassette sitting on the music board and
it's the cassette that changed my
life the cassette was by an artist a rat
pioneer named dana dane dana was a
brooklyn-born artist his first album was
one of my favorite albums and this was
an advanced copy in the late 80s that
nobody
nobody had sitting there i wanted to
listen to it so i asked the engineer if
i could borrow the cassette and i would
bring the cassette back after i listened
to it he said sure
a couple of days later i'm on my way to
los angeles to visit a friend i'm
listening to it in my sony walkman if
anyone remembers those sony walkman yeah
and when i'm on the plane i read that
the owner of delicious finals favorite
artist this is a big label tone loke and
young his favorite artist is dana dane
so when i land in california i cold
called delicious vinyl i get all the way
up to the assistant of this guy she has
no idea what i'm talking about i'm
talking very fast like a new yorker i
have dana's tape i know mike's a fan of
dana
she puts me on hold
she comes back two minutes later and she
says dana
if you can be here at two o'clock mike
ross would love to meet you
dana will be there two o'clock
two o'clock comes the dana dana's a
brooklyn-born guy like i said
african-american goldtooth
not me
i pushed the
now a good friend of mine though
push the button they said i said hey i'm
dana here from micros oh
mike is expecting you dana come right in
i walk in they escort me into the office
loke's record young's record he's got
this funky candle going they sit me down
i'm sitting there i'm waiting no idea
what's going to happen in walks
mike ross
and says to me not as politely who in
the world are you
there's a famous quote by harry truman
if you can't convince them
confuse them
it works so far
so i start saying oh i work at the same
studio as dana i know you're a fan of
dana he must be late he has an advanced
tape
can i put in my cassette that i did at
the in the studio you have a cassette
what do you do
i wrap
huh put it in
put in my cassette and he says the four
words that every artist struggling
artist wants to hear
who's your lawyer
i don't have a lawyer i have a dad so i
give him my dad's number my dad owns a
plumbing
my dad owns a plumbing supply house in
mineola
i call my father when we leave i said
dad i think i just got a record deal if
someone calls you
we got our foot in the door we're going
to figure the rest out later get all the
documents
that started a journey of getting my
foot in the door
and figuring it out later a key thing in
creativity starting the process trusting
the process and letting it evolve
because if you don't get your foot in
the door if you don't start
nothing happens i did it with a company
called marquee jet we sold it to warren
buffett i did it with our company's eco
coconut water we sold it to coca-cola at
one point i think you were writing the
number of days you had on your wrist or
something like that i stopped doing that
why'd you stop i'm curious um i'm just
so aware of it now you know um
uh it was starting to freak my wife out
a little bit uh it's a little depressing
but for me it's not depressing
it's like you know
i think people's relationship with time
we talk about relationships with humans
how's your relationship with your kids
how your relationship with your wife you
know your dad or your parents but we
never talk about a relationship with
money and time
and the relation your relationship with
time is such a key component
of your life because when you get caught
in a routine
time goes so quickly when you understand
that there are maybe only 28 summers
left
and if you want to truly you know get as
much out of experientially out of life
it just creates a tremendous amount of
urgency
so uh and the fear goes away
because you're like [ __ ] man nobody on
the planet like everybody no one's gonna
be here in a hundred years do i care
what he thinks that like he's not we're
not going to be here in 100 years so why
would i take the chance
and it's just i don't know it's just so
i stopped writing it because i'm so
aware of it there's not a day that goes
by when my head hits the pillow where i
don't say to myself like you know did i
maximize the day and am i and you know
am i aware of
my mortality and it might sound
depressing but it's it's not for me it's
um it's thrilling
it's thrilling so how is turning 50
affecting the way that you think i'm
super curious
just realizing that like it went so fast
and realizing that there's so much that
i want to do and being aware
that your 70s are a different decade
than your 40s and 50s
then you have 20
years left
and when you real put it in perspective
of how many weekends there are you know
there's only 52 weekends and you start
to look at it like that you're like i'm
going to be 80 in 30 years
scary
you know i got kids it's scary because
there's a lot i want to do i feel like i
haven't done anything compared to what i
what i want to do
and
the opportunities
so
you know it just how do you manage your
time i never thought like that i'm
thought i'm going to live forever
and um you know i'm bulletproof and all
that stuff and i'm not and when you turn
50 [ __ ] happens
friends get sick you know
let me give you an example of of just
how it's affected me and how even the
monastery and this whole notion of time
which we've been talking it's been a
theme of this conversation
but like um are your parents alive yeah
how old are your parents if you're all
right 70 okay and where do they live
in different parts of washington state
okay do you see them yeah pretty often
once to three times a year okay so let's
say they live to be 78 which is the i
hope they don't well let's say that they
live to the average age
so you see him one said once to three
times yeah okay no you don't it means
you're going to see him 16 if you see
him twice a year you can see him 16 more
times
when you look at it that way
you're like what
you don't have
eight years with them
you have 16 times with them
and that's the shift in my life and
that's the way i look at things
that's a fundamental shift in the way
that i looked at
situations six months ago
and it's created urgency it's created um
a need to just like not put stuff off
and to recognize like what's on your
list of things that you want to do
warren is probably the most rational
person i've ever met charlie munger
would be a close rival
and charlie became a man that warren
depended on heavily
and i think his first experiences in the
discarded cigar but era convinced them
that it was not exactly where he wanted
to be
he'd made so much money for so long
doing what he'd been taught by ben
graham which should buy these very cheap
stocks if they were cheap enough he
didn't care it was a lousy company and
lousy management he knew he was going to
make money anyway just because of the
cheapness
charlie munger has had a big impact on
me in
moving me toward looking for wonderful
companies at fair prices rather than
fair companies at wonderful prices and
that was enormously important because it
enabled berkshire to scale up in a way
that would have been impossible to do
otherwise we were metal partners right
from the moment we met
i want to know going back 50 years what
it was like when you first met warren
well i thought he was a prodigy
and i got a lot of criticism my wife
said why are you paying such enormous
respect to that young man with a crew
cut who won't eat vegetables
he's ungodly smart he's got a much
broader intellect than i do
and he's magnificent at being able to
condense important ideas into just a
very few words
if you're not interested in the economic
scene right now
you're mentally dead
charlie has no tax all right let's talk
a little bit about bankers charlie on
friday compared them to heroin addicts
yeah well that's colorful charlie but i
would not have chosen that
i once wrote of him that when they
handed out humility he didn't get his
fair share
the ideal way to run a headquarters is
to have one man
preferably over 80 sitting in an office
by himself
anything else is pure frippery
he's always honest than what he tells me
so i i listened to him
we never had an argument
we just
we just kind of roll with it easily
[Music]
suppose warren doesn't want to do
something that i would have done
and suppose that happens four times over
40 years or something
what the hell difference does it make to
me
net the record is working out fine what
are the key indicators you look for
within companies before making an
investment
well i look for something that does give
them a motor rod
[Music]
we have a company called sea's candy out
on the west coast sea's candies box
chocolates
if you give a box of sea chocolates to
your girlfriend of the first day and she
kisses you
we own you you know
we can raise the price tomorrow you'll
buy the same box you're not going to
fool around with success so
the key there is the response
you do not want to go home on
valentine's day and say to your wife or
your sweetheart
preferably they're the same person you
don't say here honey i took the low bid
it doesn't work price is
to a degree is immaterial if you've got
a economic castle people are going to
come and want to take that castle away
from you and you better have a strong
moan you better have a nightmare castle
that knows what he's doing what advice
would you give someone who's wondering
like how do i find my passion and how do
i pull on these threads and and
where are they going to lead to help us
understand how you got started and how
they should think about it well i think
i mean most
um
most people
listening to this show know know what
their passion is and um
and they may it could be a hobby it
could be
um you know they could love reading they
could love playing tennis they could
they'll have passions
um and if you have a passion uh
it makes sense to spend a lot of your
life in involved in that passion
um and quite often you can turn your
passion uh into a business you can see
um
that maybe there's some aspect of your
passion that people are not doing that
well and um and
you know you can say screw it you know i
i could i could i i could do it better
um and i think all you know if you spend
your life with your eyes open looking
for
um looking for things that frustrate you
looking for a gap gaps in the market
um that's all the business is is it's
fulfilling that you know filling in a
gap and doing it better than it's been
done by anybody else
um
and
uh
and
and you know it it people who don't have
closed minds will most likely find find
that or find those opportunities
now i suspect there will be
a hundred people who will have come up
with that idea before you um
but those hundred people
um you know won't have had the courage
just to go and do something about it so
um you know so those few people who just
say right you know that
i'm going to give it a go
um that and often end up um
you know being being successful we set
up three airlines um virgin australia
virgin america and virgin atlantic and
um and they've all been very successful
and they've been successful
i think well i mean most business is
successful because of the people but the
people
uh
only excel
if you give them the tools to do a great
job and if they if they feel like sure
and then
so i think um you know what was critical
in virgin atlantic was that all every
single little detail um was right so we
were you know we were the first airline
to introduce seat back videos and
five years before british airways and
you know kids who traveled on on virgin
uh would not let their their parents
travel on any other airline bishops they
wanted to
they wanted seatback videos and
um
you know we had stand-up bars for you
know upper-class passengers and
uh i'm sure lots of romances started at
our at our upper class bars
and we're not the kind of airline that
banged on lavatory doors either
[Applause]
is it going to be a business kind of
tourism in in orbit or is it
more kind of plan b if things on earth
do not develop as well
it's not exactly a plan b
it's it's more that i think i think
there's two two aspects to this
one is that we want to have a future
that is inspiring and exciting
and what are the things that you find
inspiring and exciting about the future
i think
one a future where we are a space faring
civilization and out there among the
stars i think that's
every kid gets excited about that you
don't even need to teach them
that they just get it it's like
instinctive
and
so
it's very important for us to have
reasons to
like reasons to be excited about life
like when you wake up in the morning it
can't just be about problems
it's okay i know everyone in this room
deals with a lot of tough problems
but you know it's got to be more than
that
so
you know i think a future where you can
say
hey even if it's not you there's going
to be people out there they're going to
we can have a base on the moon we're
gonna have a you know
a city on mars maybe go further the
moons of jupiter and everything
i think that's a very exciting future so
this was x.com as a precursor to paypal
basically yeah you merged with confinity
and it became paypal major success yeah
so it worked out better than we expected
um
yeah um
so yeah
confinity so
initially infinity and x.com started out
with from slightly different directions
and it converged to the same point um
with with x the thought was to create an
integrated set of financial services
um so that you could go to one place and
do all of your financial anything
and and then as a feature we have the
ability to transfer money or securities
or anything simply by entering a unique
identifier so like a
you know email address or phone number
or something like that
and uh when we demo the system the hard
stuff which was the integration of all
the
financial services uh people would not
be interested in but they'd be really
interested in it and being able to
transfer money using an email address
you know that was actually quite easy
and so we focused our energy on that um
and although it's easy in principle
it
what gets really hard is is adding um
security while still keeping it easy to
use
so because
you know it's like the woolly lemon
quote like why do people why do you want
banks because that's where the money is
so a lot of people run paypal same
reason
um
and and so you can you can dial up the
security to a really high level but then
you're going to make it very hard to use
and and so that that that was that was
one of the toughest things we wrestled
with
and then confinity the key to making
things affordable is is like designing
it is like design and technology
improvements as well as scale so if you
think of like say um phones
um like the very earliest like the
earliest cell phones like
uh i'm probably like dating myself here
but uh like the original wall street
where the guy's like walking down the
beach and he's got like the it's like on
a giant phone he's carrying on like a
briefcase kind of thing they're
massively like massive massive phone
yeah and like all i could do is phone
yep
yep um and like had like 30 minutes of
battery life and that kind of thing
um now at that time uh in the absence of
technology improvements like no amount
of money no amount of scale could have
made that phone affordable that'd be a
lot of engineering iterations a lot of
design iterations um
and we're probably i don't know on the
30th version of of a cell phone or
and and with each successive design
iteration uh you can add more capability
you can design you can integrate more
things you figure out uh better ways to
produce it
so it actually gets better and cheaper
but it's like it's like a natural
progression of any new technology that
it takes multiple versions and a large
volume in order to make it affordable
nobody's journey is seamless or smooth
we all stumble we all have setbacks if
things go wrong you hit a dead end as
you will
it's just life's way of saying
time to change course
so ask every failure this is what i
do every failure every crisis every
difficult time i say what is this here
to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson
you get to move on if you really get the
lesson you pass and you don't have to
repeat the class if you don't get the
lesson it shows up wearing another pair
of pants
or skirt
to give you some remedial work
and what i found is that difficulties
come when you don't pay attention to
life's whisper
because life always whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
whisper sooner or later you'll get a
scream
whatever you resist persists but if you
ask the right question not why is this
happening but what is this here to teach
me what is this here to teach me it puts
you in the place and space to get the
lesson you need my friend ed cartoli
uh who's written this wonderful book
uh called a new earth
it's all about letting the awareness of
who you are stimulate everything that
you do he puts it like this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge with that situation instead and
the solution will arise from the
challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
hennessey said i started this school
in africa
and
i founded the school where i'm trying to
give south african girls a shot at a
future like yours stanford
and i spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students
i wanted every girl to feel her worth
reflected in her surroundings so i
checked every blueprint
i picked every pillow
i was looking at the grout in between
the bricks i knew every thread count of
the sheets i chose every girl from the
villages from nine provinces and yet
last fall i was faced with a crisis i'd
never anticipated i was told that one of
the dorm matrons was suspected of sexual
abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first i cried actually i sobbed for
about a half an hour
and then i said let's get to it that's
all you get is a half an hour you need
to focus on the now
what you need to do now so i contacted a
child trauma specialist i put together a
team of investigators i made sure the
girls had counseling and support and
gail and i got on a plane and flew to
south africa and the whole time i kept
asking that question
what is this here to teach me
and as difficult as that experience has
been
i got a lot of lessons
i understand now the mistakes i made
because i
had been paying attention to all of the
wrong things
i built that school from the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out
so it's a lesson that applies to all of
our lives as a whole what matters most
is what's inside what matters most is
the sense of
integrity of quality and beauty i got
that lesson and what i know is is that
the girls came away with something too
they've emerged from this more resilient
and knowing that their voices
have power now before we came here
deepak chopra
great thought leader of our times i had
called him wanting to do an interview
with him and he said he was going to be
coming to india and i i i have a vision
board i keep a vision board first vision
board ever ever started was to get
barack obama elected so i just had
barack obama
and then i went back
and that vision board was right by my
in my bathroom by the bathtub so every
morning i would say barack obama
president barack obama
and then uh this is in 2007 and then i
decided i had to go back and put 2008 so
that whoever was listening would know i
didn't mean barack obama president 2012
or 2016. so i only had that as a vision
and then i put a picture after barack
obama won
i put a picture i cut out of a magazine
of a woman on a camel
in and it said come to india
come to india
and i've held that as my vision
on my vision board for the past three
years so when this idea of coming with
deepak i went now it's time to fulfill
the vision so first impression coming in
the city chaotic and then being in the
city with
more people than i've ever encountered
in my life
but still feeling not a sense of being
unsafe if you could go back and talk to
your younger self
go build the time machine and go back
and talk to your younger self what what
advice would you give the younger you
that maybe you didn't realize about
yourself that you wish you did when you
were younger
well the first thing that pops into my
mind is that he shows up
he shows up he shows up and i think he's
sitting in the audience here but i spent
a lot of time as a younger self worrying
about am i going to meet the right one
am i going to be able to have children
am i going to start a family and i would
tell my younger self just chill out he
shows up just do your thing don't spend
any mental energy on that but it's hard
you know especially as a woman i really
wanted to be financially independent i
wanted to chart my own way but i also
was really wanting to to be a mother and
have another side of my life so
that's what i would say very good he
shows up he took his time i didn't get
married till i was 37 38
but now we have four children let me
back up for one second i actually
really manifested the idea
so you know it's like everyone's always
like how did you take an idea and then
start a business well it's how did you
even come up with the idea you know i
was in search of my idea and at the time
my life was not great i was selling fax
machines door-to-door i was living with
my mom i was like 25 years old and i
remember after a whole entire day of
being kicked out of office complexes
again all day or sometimes my business
card ripped up in my face i pulled off
the side of the road one day kathy and i
was like i'm in the wrong movie like
what just happened
call the director call the producer
this is not my life this is not my movie
and i went home that night i wrote down
my strengths or what i thought i was
good at and the only thing in the good
column really was sales
and i thought okay well i know i'm good
at selling what is it i like about
selling and i realized i like offering
something to someone that they need or
didn't know that they needed that can
improve their life or help them and
so in that moment i wrote down in my
journal i want to invent a product that
i can sell to millions of people that
will make them feel good
and
um and you know what and two years later
the idea came to me
and
and i was ready for it you know people
women had been cutting the feet out of
their panties for a long time and i only
did it one time but i had already asked
the universe for my idea and i said when
it comes i will not squander it and i
will take it and run with it one of the
things i also do is i like to go up to
people at spanx and i say i'm always
trying to get people off autopilot like
if you think about it everything we do
almost everything we do in life is
autopilot we're doing things exactly the
way someone else showed us how to do it
or taught us how to do it well if you're
doing things exactly the way everyone
else is there's no there's not going to
be any real significant change there's
not going to be a really meaningful
potential breakthrough so
i always go up to people at spanx and
say if nobody showed you how to do your
job how would you be doing it
i'll say just sit with that you know i'm
always like i'll stop myself often and
just say okay
you know
this is how i've been doing it but is
this right and give yourself the time to
think about it so i asked people to do
that the best advice i could give is
number one be prepared for a lot of
rejection
if you're ready for rejection of people
say no i don't want it no it's not going
to work no this is crazy whatever if
you're prepared for it it's not going to
let you down learn from your failures i
had a lot of failures along the way even
with my patron and paul mitchell but we
learn from those things and we get a lot
better when god created this planet
he created up several species
now if you're an atheist it's okay call
it the force let me just say god for now
so i don't have to say the god the
forest god the forest let's just say god
right now god creates a planet earth and
first of all he creates which a lot of
people in different organizations want a
perfect social economic world where
everything is free don't worry about a
thing you're taken care of there's no
extra imagination necessary it's all
going to be given to you so he creates
the oyster he says oyster i'm giving you
a free house to live in i'm calling it a
shell i'm gonna put at the bottom of the
ocean
to protect you from your enemies you
have food clothing all the food you want
protection
everything you want the perfectly taken
care of while you're in your measly
little life as an oyster but you're not
going to go anywhere
you stay there at the bottom of the
ocean but you totally got your free food
free clothing free everything you want
then god created something called the
eagle eagle whole different species
eagle you want a house you go out and
build it
take the top of a mountain take the top
of a tree go out and build your own
house you want some food to eat no
problem go out there and find it eagle
and the eagle flies through miles in the
winter time of rain sleet snow and wind
just to feed its young
did you know the eagle
fails 95
of the time a total failure it's so big
and cumbersome that when it comes upon
its prey they're wild they shoot off in
a different direction and it misses
five percent of the time it succeeds and
what does it succeed to do it succeeded
to be the strongest bird in the sky
the only one that we know of anywhere in
the world that could fly into the
thermals of a hurricane and ride them to
have fun
now the eagle unlike the oyster can go
anywhere it wants anywhere it wants yeah
gambles it does this on its own but it
goes wherever it wants
now that eagle and not the oyster is the
emblem of america
and also on the flag of many many
countries you wouldn't be in this room
right now if you weren't eagles don't
only imagine start doing it when i
worked for other companies some of them
not to mention any names
were so
bad
they would treat people the old way i'm
the boss here's what you're gonna do
because i'm the boss right or there were
times for example where maybe had a
dollar for lunch you can't get allowed
for a dollar so i just knew that that's
how i was and if i had a company
that i had control of my gosh everyone's
gonna be treated the way i wanted to be
treated so the minute we could afford it
everyone had free lunch whether you had
money or not you have free lunch we pay
for it for you carpool will pay for that
so we started doing things for people
that i wish happened to me
maybe that's part of fate maybe because
a lot of things along the way weren't so
good that as things started getting good
it was so easy for me to share with our
people so easy to do that people
sometimes don't save money
as soon as we possibly could afford it
we started profit sharing we're at the
end of every year and we'll take that
profit sharing and put in a retirement
fund for you it's yours it's yours if
you're so many years it goes with you no
matter where you go but it's yours
that's your money
that's really incredible and how much do
you think that that sort of golden rule
approach has fed into your
ridiculously low turnover rate which is
literally
almost unprecedented i mean that's crazy
i try and treat people exactly the way
they'd want to be treated exactly or the
way i would have wanted to be treated
i'm happy with my people i realize my
people are the company if my people go
my god the company goes people are your
company and they take care of the
customer the customer is always right no
matter what so what do we do so the
customers happier if somebody's unhappy
would try and discover why
and because you treat people this way
and we love them you walk in our company
it's love if you go to the front desk
here in century city this girl just has
the biggest smile saying hi welcome to
john paul mitchell system she loves what
she does
our big problem is
we don't have turnover we have so many
people out of work for us and the thing
is you gotta wait for somebody to die
now as we grow we'll add one or two on
obviously at a time sure and we're
pretty big now because we're in 96
countries if i had email i would be
inundated i choose not to have email or
ever turn a computer on now all my
companies are state of the art
technologically advanced if i want
something printed out it's printed out
for me but i do this out of choice
i'd rather make a phone call to you or
write you a letter and communicate the
way you deserve to be communicated with
and no disrespect to people on email and
i'd be so inundated my gosh i'd be on my
computer all day long i prefer to have
that personal touch and it seems to work
with all the companies i have that i'm
quite active in but i have great
presence running most of them thank god
a very blessed error right to take care
of the details but i'm still hands-on in
many many of the businesses here and
it's i can work better that way and it
goes down to this
pay attention to the vital few ignore
the trivia many if i had email
no disrespect there'd be a lot of trivia
on there i'd be answering i try and pay
attention to the vital few and ignore
the trivia what do you differentiate
those those two categories to be like
where would let's say your president be
and where would like the head of a sales
division be are they on two sides of
that equation no what it is is if it's
one of my companies you could call me
directly but people know call me
directly if you have to but don't bother
me with something someone else can
handle they do it it works really really
fine works really well but uh what's
important would be obviously presence of
company anyone that's involved with me
either philanthropically the main people
philanthropically are the main people in
my businesses or places or countries i
want to reach out to the head of a
country will call me i'll call them
right back you know things that are very
significant insignificant our i'll give
you an example in my life it has been
significant i'm hit up every month for
hundreds of requests send me a hundred
dollars send me two million dollars you
have all the money share it with me and
i just i don't even touch it i can't i'm
i'm swarmed i do so much philanthropy
now everyone expects that whether it's a
two million dollar mortgage or hey i
want to start a new business send me
fifty thousand dollars because you have
money i don't that people should do well
that's not true
i spend millions on philanthropic work
but i do it through our foundation where
it really makes sense not where i have
to go through it all right so i think
when dreams start to brew in us or when
there's like a seed planted in us where
we have this dream it kind of started
that way where i was like like it was
like a little inkling like wait a minute
if i if i could figure out how to
launch it how to create a product that
works for me i better help a lot of
other people yeah and then i would kind
of like silence that dream and i would
my head would take over oh jamie you
have no connections you have barely any
money you don't know anything about the
beauty industry and you're you're in
your dream job right now right and so it
was i went through that battle and i
think everyone listening to us right now
probably like really if they get still
they probably know right now
if there's a dream on their heart or or
something they know
what they're supposed to create or go
after or offer the world or start
painting again or start dancing right
they kind of know
um but sometimes our head talks
ourselves out of our lives absolutely
sometimes
it's like god has other plans it's like
something hits you and you don't even
know and well frankly the things going
through my mind were what's you know
what's what's going on what's wrong with
me uh uh i would try i would spend my
makeup trying to cover it up because
rosacea's bright red and you get these
um patches on your skin and they're
textured like sandpaper like a rash
right almost yes and it's very textured
and so um no i mean i think anytime you
know something happens to us whether
it's a physical thing a physical change
an emotional
situation um something with our health
right any time we have something like
that you know the the
it's hard
to go through the the beginning of it
because i struggled a little bit
honestly i had thoughts like okay
am i pretty anymore like just those
things like i'm embarrassed i never even
said that out loud by the way but like
that's the truth i just started doubting
myself i started um
doubting okay is this gonna affect my
career you know but
in in the midst of the the start of kind
of that that i guess struggle of going
okay
my physical appearance is changing let
me wrap my head around this um uh is
when i started really looking into
makeup and and trying everything out
there spending my tiny paycheck on on uh
every product i could get my hands on
from the most expensive to the least
expensive and and uh there's that famous
saying like you know sometimes we make
our mess our message and that's sort of
what happened it was this
entrepreneurial moment where
i realized there's nothing out there
that works for me right nothing that
will solve my problem and there must be
so many other people that have just
given up on makeup because it doesn't
work for them and it's like okay
nothing works and and
the more i researched i'm like wow
seventy percent of women have
hyperpigmentation wow
all of us yeah yeah that's like oh you
know what i mean and so many of us deal
with just all different uh things
hormonal changes everything acne and so
i just thought you know what
if i can solve this problem for me i
know that it could be you know of
service and life-changing for for other
people always um
very focused on sort of the structure of
these companies and how how well are
people aligned and so you can um
and uh making sure that people are you
know aligned properly not just that they
say i think this is sort of a very a
very legal kind of a framework to think
about what are people's incentives you
know are they going to be aligned or not
and i think you want to both have formal
alignment where you set the structure
right and you want to have
informal alignment where the people
would naturally try to work together
well in one one way or another um
and i think that somehow tends to get
obscured in all these other ways
you know there's always a there's always
a uh there's always a prehistory
question i like to ask founders of of
companies which is um
how did you uh how did you um
meet what's the prehistory of the
company before you got started
i find that to be really instructive a
set of questions to ask a bad answer is
something like you know we met a week
ago
at a social networking function at a
business networking function we decided
to start a company because we both
wanted to be entrepreneurs um you know
that's like saying i married the first
person i met at the slot machines in las
vegas and you might hit the jackpot but
it's probably a really bad idea um and a
much better answer is you know we've
been talking about this for a long time
you know maybe
one of us is more on the tech side the
other one's more on the business side we
have these sort of complementary skills
and and so i think this question of
alignment and structure is is incredibly
important on an individual level i think
it is always uh it's always really good
if if there's something that you're
incredibly passionate about and um and
just sort of are find to be
intrinsically interesting and uh and
that that people pursue that um and so
the you know one of the
one of the the resolutions i came up
with a number of years ago was to always
uh
value substance over status substance
over prestige um
and you know if i sort of was giving my
younger self advice on what to what to
do or how to how to think about um
your when's one's life
i you know i probably i think i you know
um i probably still go to stanford um
you know i i might still go to law
school um but i'd ask i'd ask sort of
i'd ask a lot more questions why why i
was doing these things and i think uh i
think if i was honest about it
too much of it was driven by
um by prestige and status and not quite
enough about um really the substance of
uh of trying to learn things and you
know i had sort of this i sort of think
of it as this sort of crazy rolling
quarter life crisis and sort of
culminated in this uh in this you know
big new york law firm where you know
from the outside everybody wanted to get
in from the inside everybody wanted to
get out
you know after i lasted seven months and
three days and after uh
um and uh when i when i when i left one
of the people down the hall said you
know it's so reassuring to see you leave
peter i had no idea it was possible to
escape from alcatraz which which again
uh and you know and again i and all you
had to do was go through the front door
but our identity um people's identities
get so wrapped up in um the things they
compete for that it was inconceivable
for people to actually do that and and
then the question was you know well how
had i ended up there why had i not
thought about that more and uh and i
think it was um that i had taken too
many of these shortcuts of valuing sort
of what was prestigious what was
conventional over what i uh what i
really want to do so i think i think
always substance over status i actually
think you should think twice before
starting certain types of businesses so
i think um there are probably too many
bad businesses getting started and not
enough good ones so that's it's um you
know i don't think there's i don't think
there's anything about entrepreneurship
per se
that is um that is is good you know i
was telling one of my friends a few
years ago i was asking him what do you
want to be doing in five or ten years oh
it's really clear i want to be an
entrepreneur that's like saying i want
to be rich i want to be famous
um and i i don't think uh i don't think
those are those are good things being
rich and famous um they're not good as
direct goals like if if you if you have
that as your sole goal you're unlikely
to i think really
really succeed and so i think you become
an entrepreneur because you're working
on an important problem nobody else is
working on i think you should start a
business if you have uh something if
you're if you're working on a problem
that otherwise would not get solved i
have seen
people and it
it happens to everybody no matter what
it is i've seen people rip you apart on
both sides
for both
how
how does that
what what what
how does that drive you does that drive
you at all does that does that on
political correctness of having to
conform and being what everybody says
you're supposed to be
does that drive you at all
well it's it's uh you try you try to you
try to ignore it to some extent you know
you try um
not to um
but you don't you know you don't try to
um you don't try to put yourself into
any of these um very uncomfortable
straight jackets and you know you don't
want um and i think that's
that's what's so uh
pernicious about all the identity
politics that uh that um you know we we
all have to be
in in this category we're all the same i
think people are all different we're all
you know we're all we're all you know
i'm somewhat idiosyncratic but i think
all of us are all of us are
idiosyncratic in different ways and i
think i think this is a this is
something that um most people experience
that they're being put into boxes way
more than they're comfortable you know
there's this interview question i always
like asking people tell me something
that's true that very few people agree
with you on
and um it's a very hard question to
answer
um and it's it's not because people
don't have answers they actually have
lots of answers to it it's because
they're uncomfortable answering it in
the context of an interview because um
you know if it has the answer has to be
something the person asking you won't
agree and we're always nervous about
doing that we always want to fit in and
this uh this this pressure to fit in is
uh
is really powerful
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want even more
advice from billionaires check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there to service
service through my work
service through my life's purpose
and if you make a commitment a conscious
intention to be committed